you remember friday night's democratic
debate yeah me neither
the high point this question is anyone
else on the stage concerned
about having a democratic socialist at
the top of the democratic ticket
i'm not senator klobuchar see that amy
klobuchar was the only one who raised
her hand we don't count bernie
which says something good about her and
something frightening about the rest
she thinks for herself as the rest cower
before the fringe
the sad thing about this crop you're
grateful for even a grain of common
sense apparently voicing disgust
of an ideological menace that helped
kill millions
is now an act of blasphemy anyway what a
mess
mayor pete is a thesaurus without
specifics liz warren is an evasive
phony joe sounded like the guy at the
bar after he got fired talking loudly
about all the stuff he did better than
everyone else
it's also kind of bad when dems say they
wouldn't kill a terrorist
who are they worried about pissing off
other terrorists
oddly they seem more spiteful of
companies which are just people
but lacking economic skills democrats
think companies
are sinister engines run by the monopoly
guy in a top hat
they plead for unity while slamming
folks who were once examples of american
opportunity
as the economy rolls on with more jobs
wages and satisfaction
they accuse half the country of
exploiting the other half
so now a reasonable democrat becomes the
fringe
as others pair at the line that america
is racist through and through
which leads to divisive factions and
punitive actions
they deny real progress with race which
puts future progress in jeopardy
how do you measure change when you
reject its existence
amy's at least rooted in some reality
which means she's toast
you uh jessie had an interesting
perception about uh
about uh amy we both think that she
might be the surprise
yes i think she'll do well tomorrow and
she could beat sleepy joe
she's right at his heels right now so
you know she could uh
really put the nail in the coffin for
for joe i think she's the only one that
really shows like she wants it
i mean you have to take this nomination
barack obama took it from hillary trump
took it from jed
they're serving up these questions about
socialism on a silver platter and
everyone's just looking around at their
shoes
these guys really have to want it but i
do get the sense that
socialism now in the democratic party is
too big to beat
they're not going to be able to put it
in a corner anymore and pretend it
doesn't exist and pay it lip service
they're going to have to make peace with
bernie with the socialist faction
at the convention because there's a good
chance he could wind up with the most
delegates
at that convention and they only have
themselves to blame with socialism
they've radicalized themselves on
twitter they've abandoned the middle
class workers in this country
and a lot of the democratic elites went
hard in with the lobbyists went harden
with
wall street and they just didn't deliver
the goods for average working class
american people
at this point if you have bernie though
a socialist at the top of the ticket who
wants the boston bomber to vote from
prison
who wants open borders who wants to
dismantle wall street
who wants to revolutionize the
capitalist system and do away
with the internal combustion engine you
when you face off against trump with
someone like that
are facing a 40-state landslide
and that's what they're going to have to
reckon with hey dana i want to play you
some sound on tape of chris matthews
would you like to hear it
please all right let's roll that for
dana
i've seen what socialism is like i don't
like it okay
it's not only not free it doesn't
frickin work it just doesn't work
yes but the thing is here's the deal
didn't he play some role
in this he's like a guy who ate a large
cake every day for 30 years
and then woke up and realized they need
a crane to get him out of bed
well i think he's sounding the alarm
because he does remember
what it was like and he remembers
watching ronald reagan crusade against
socialism
and how that built a generation of
people that were very pro-capitalist
and pro-america and i think he realizes
that those people in america still exist
bernie sanders is right that no matter
who the nominee is though
they will they're going to have to
reckon with this issue they will
probably be labeled
as a socialist maybe not directly by
president trump but that will be
the message from supporters and they're
going to have to figure out a way to
deal with it
and i think this also falls just a lot
along generational
lines these polls that came out today
show that bernie sanders has got a
really good grip on the youth like
younger people
and somebody like a biden has the older
people because i think that this
socialism issue it's not just about
temperament i think it is also about the
issues biden does have a good grip on
younger people but not in the way
you should katie what are your thoughts
on this social do you think this is
overblown or no i don't
i think that people severely
underestimate the socialism message that
is based on lies i have a t-shirt that
says
socialism communism killed 100 million
people and all i got was this lousy
t-shirt
young people when you ask them what
socialism is they can't actually define
it and by the democrats not standing up
and saying yes i have a problem with it
on the stage it proves
that there are no moderates running in
the democratic party and they deserve
the label
of being socialists and bernie sanders
you know the question on msnbc after
chris matthews said that was
well is he like a denmark socialist or
is he like a cuban communist
and if you go back and listen to bernie
sanders own words about cuban communism
he was excited about fidel castro who is
responsible for the murder
of hundreds of thousands of people uh he
said that breadlines in
nicaragua were a good example of how the
economy works so
when we're talking about policy here
these aren't just differences
in minor policies these are about two
completely different structures for the
future of the country and it should not
be underestimated considering how many
young people
are falling for the messaging on it hey
juan i have a theory about amy klobuchar
i think she might be
trump's toughest challenge because if
candidates were like a mountain that you
have to climb
it's hard to find the nooks and crannies
on klobuchar
that you can like you can call liz
warren pocahontas you can call
biden old and and frail and and uh
bernie socialist but what do you call
her
nothing i'm sure he'd come up with
something he's pretty good at nicknames
and bullying people
uh you know i i i just watch you guys
and i think wait a minute
these guys are so pro-bernie but now
they're going anti-burning i'm thinking
oh they must see
bernie as really coming on right
but but let me just say with regard to
bernie in this con this comment which is
the president said last week he's a
communist
the socialist thing is just wacky i mean
look he's not for having
the government control the means of
production in this country
hang on what bernie's talking about and
by the way
most democrats support is the idea that
you need a stronger social safety net
in this country to deal with health care
to deal with the hype that's not a
safety
net wait hold on let me finish the deal
with the high cost of education
especially
college education debt that is such a
problem
for young people and not only that you
have so many
issues that already we are so-called
socialist on
if you want to go at social security i
know the president said
to his big rich friends over in davos
yeah well you know we have to look at
medicare
that's socialism but that's because we
are a caring american and they're all
going when it comes to our elders all of
the programs are going
broke you guys just go on and on you
won't let me talk
but i'm just telling you this is not
this is not
children this is a this is america
caring about its people and that's what
you're seeing from
not only presidents and caring and
that's what you're seeing from democrats
who support that
red lines aren't compassionate this is
not breadlines this is fair wages
instead of giving tax cuts to the rich
which is a socialism of a different kind
but it's not my kind maybe that's